let's go back to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3
0 47 50 and see what is on the minds of
folks who are calling in today starting
with our caller from the three zero one
area code
who's calling from three zero one today
hi this is Johnny hey John hey I have a
question and a comment and my comment is
you know I'm from DC and I really avoid
any superfluous political analysis but I
really enjoy your show and I just
started listening like maybe a week or
so ago thank you so I appreciate your
take on things I appreciate that
yeah and so my question is with the
impeachment scandal if we could sort of
zoom out for a second and look at a
larger picture of how the u.s. bargains
with foreign countries in terms of aid
so I actually work in the disaster
relief industry in aid so my question is
what are your takes on how aid needs to
change abroad and how we how we engage
with other countries and foreign powers
this is a big topic so you have number
one you have aid that then is given with
the explicit or implicit condition that
the money is spent back in the United
States on weapons so this is the case
like with Saudi Arabia some of the aid
to Israel and there's other countries so
that is something that one side argues
is great for the economy because we're
giving aid and then it's coming right
back and supporting jobs and whatnot but
it's a pretty corrupt and ugly reality
and that's that's one type of aid that
is problematic another type of aid that
is problematic is aid where you are not
really helping the country to I'm trying
to use the right words here you're
you're giving aid in a way that serves
as a band-aid rather than treating the
problem so to speak so I've talked
before about
there's lots of aid that for example
goes to some place and provides
eyeglasses and shoes for people or
something like that but if you don't
actually help the country establish
infrastructure where they can have a
doctors that are treating people and
they can get shoes without them having
to be handed over or whatever the case
may be it's really only a band-aid it's
not a long-term solution so I mean
there's so many different ways that this
needs to be tackled and changed okay
right so um just I guess in in in terms
of how the impeachment scandal has
raised awareness about how like you said
ugly the aide transactional relationship
yeah between foreign power looks how do
you think in the future things are going
to change knowing that Republicans and
Democrats alike have been very generous
for other a saving activities that don't
include weapons that don't include like
you said these you know one-stop shop
for for basic American products are sold
in foreign countries using a congruent
budget how do you think the conversation
is going to be change moving forward but
whatever the outcome of the impeachment
I I mean you're talking because the
impeachment hearings are over the quid
pro quo bribery use whatever word you
want relating to the military aid and
the smearing of Biden you mean how will
that change aid in the future correct
yeah I don't know that it will actually
I mean so you're you're certainly going
to have some defenders of Trump who say
listen we negotiate all the time we
don't just give aid we give it in
exchange for the money being spent in
the US or we give it in exchange for
this or that the the key of course
that's very disingenuous because here
it's a president doing it for a very
specific personal benefit which is he
wants a better shot at defeating Joe
Biden if that's who he ends up running
against in 2020 so you'll have
Republicans who will make that argument
but big picture I mean we don't tend to
learn for these really big things like
campaign finance foreign aid the
corporate ah cracy we tend not really to
learn from things when they go wrong so
I have no expectation that anything's
gonna change really okay thanks for your
perspective David presented all right
thank you for the call I appreciate it